طبعا رمضان كريم وكل عام وانتم بالف الف
خير ربما هي نصف ساعه مرت على اذان المغرب
وبالتالي قبل ساعه من الان كانت الشوارع
تعج بالحياه كانت الناس تذهب لشراء الخبز
لشراء الحلويات
للذهاب لمجاوره بعضهم البعض ولكن الان ثلث
ساعه مرت على اذان المغرب وبالتالي
الشوارع هادئه جدا لا توجد حركه الان
الناس يعني في بيوتها في المطاعم تتناول
وجبه الافطار وبالتالي هذا المشهد من خلفه
انا الان في احد الشوارع في العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان في جبل عمان بالتحديد يعني
هناك حركه بسيطه قد تعود بعد ساعه عمان
وباقي المدن الى الحياه ولكن اذان المغرب
يفرض البرتقالات معينه وبالتالي يعني
محلات الحلويات كانت على اشدها وبيع
الحلويات القطائف
الهريسه وايضا الكنافه دعيني اعرج على
موضوع بان الاردنيين شهر رمضان يعانون من
ارتفاع الاسعار وبالتالي يعني بروتوكول او
عرف من اعراف رمضان هو العزائم هو عرف
وتقليل والاردنيين دائما يشتهرون بالكرم
احد المطاعم بالتعاون مع احد شركات
التمويل قام بلفته معينه وهو تمويل
العزومه على ثلاث اشهر يعني انا بامكاني
ان اقوم بعزيمه العائله وبطبيعه الحال
العوائل الاردنيه هي عوائل ممتده يعني
وبالتالي اقست هذه العزيمه تعرض هذا العرض
لبعض الانتقاد من رواد التواصل الاجتماعي
ولكن البعض مال له خاصه وان الاردنيين او
معظم الاردنيين يعتمدون في حياتهم على
التقسيط من شراء البيت او شراء حتى الهاتف
المحمول او عربه القياده وبالتالي يعني
البعض كان مع هذا الموضوع والبعض لم يكن
مع هذا الموضوع ولكن يعني بالتالي ربما ان
ارتفاع الاسعار قد يخفف هذا العب هذا
العرض من هذه الشركه وهذا قد يدفع
الكثيرين من الاردنيين الاعتماد العزيمه
والعزيمه الكبيره اسقاط العزائم من شهر
رمضان قد لا يعني قد لا يمكن في شهر رمضان
الاردنيين تعودوا منذ زمن لحد الان ان
يكون رمضان مرتبط بالعزائم وبالتالي هذا
قد يخفف نوعا ما على الاردنيين ولكن هناك
طبعا يعني هناك اهدار في العزائم وفي
الطعام وكميات الطعام المهدوره هي كميات
كبيره جدا بالتالي قد نكون في المنتصف ان
يذهب الاردني للعزيمه وتواصل مع الاهل
وصله الرحم ولكن بدون اهدار ربما انا مع
هذه الخطوه بان تكون العزائم بالتقسيط في
ظل ارتفاع الاسعار الذين نلبسه جميعا
وجميع الطبقات الاردنيه يعني يعني من
الغني الى الفقير يلمس ارتفاع الاصغاء
الاسعار خاصه اللحوم اللحوم الحمراء
واللحوم البيضاء وبالتالي يعني الاردني
كريم وسيبقى يعزم حتى لم تكن هناك شركه
لهذا الموضوع على درسنا على راسنا النشامى
واكيد يعني احنا ما حبينا حتى نعمل لك
المقابله بالتقسيط اعطيناك مجال تحكي كل
شيء عندك بس انا شايفه الشوارع فاضيه لانه
موعد افطار كانه بس كيف بدها تحمسينا قولي
لنا شو بيصير يا سهى بعد الافطار كيف
بتصير شوارع رمضان في الاردن بالذات وشو
هو الطبق الرمضاني المتصيد سواء حلو او
مالح
طبعا الطبق الرمضاني ان كان على سفره
رمضان هو طبعا معظم العوائل تقوم باعداد
طبق المنسف يعني هو معروف من العاده
والتقليد وبعد ذلك ممكن المسخن المقلوبه
يعني وبعد ذلك تبدا طبعا هو سيد الاطباق
في رمضان او في غير رمضان طبعا انواع
الحلو هو معروف القطايف القطايف بالجوز او
القطايف
بالقشطه او حتى بعض العوائل الاردنيه تقوم
بعمل القطائف بالتمر الاجواء بعد رمضان هي
اجواء حيويه ربما اننا هذه الفتره هناك
يعني رمضان هذا غريب جدا نحن نعيش الان في
منخفض جوي درجات الحراره متدنيه جدا قد
يخفف من حركه المواطنين ولكن بالعكس
الاجواء تكون حيويه اسواق خاصه وسط البلد
يعني الناس تذهب ربما لا تشتري شيئا
ولكنها تذهب لترويح عن نفسها هناك بعض
المطاعم المتوازنه من الفول والحمص قد
يذهب المواطن الاردني يعني تناول وجبه
السحور بها يعني اجواء رمضان هي اجواء
معروفه صله الرحم تكثر في هذه الاجواء
والاجواء الحميميه ولمت العائله هي اهم
شيء واتمنى في يعني رمضان قادم وقادم ان
تكونوا يعني زوارنا في شهر رمضان في
الاردن حتى نقدم الواجب ولن تكون العزومه
طبعا بالتقسيط
اكيد انتم خير وبركه وشكرا جزيلا لسها
جميل واكيد سنكون معكم في ايام واشهر
مقبره شكرا